[Music]
this weekend car racing fans will have a
chance to see the
superstar racing experience a new event
debuting on cbs that aims to rival
nascar
some of the sport's top drivers will
compete head to head behind the wheel
and it turns out the steering wheel
itself has an unlikely connection
to the catholic church chris livesay
visited the specialized company in
northern italy
that makes steering wheels and
embroidery for popes
good morning chris good morning american
race cars are prided for their handling
engineering and
speed but all that horsepower can't turn
a lap without the craftsmanship from
right here in northern italy plus an
attention to detail
that's even caught the eye of two popes
what do 200 mile an hour race cars have
in common with the 2
thousand year old catholic church
[Music]
well it's all in the stitching
the stitching of handmade steering
wheels and the stitching of pope's
hats johnny ansi manages mpi
a company that makes bespoke steering
wheels here outside verona
italy so this is all handmade
[Music]
first the base is forged in aluminum and
covered in custom leather
this one to mark a race on the 4th of
july now this may seem like a small part
of the car but when you consider
this is where the driver's skill comes
in direct contact with the machine
every tiny detail here packs a huge
punch
on the track and a huge punch in the
catholic church
you see each steering wheel is
embroidered by husband and wife duo
rosana castagna and armando benini
their list of clients stretches from
nascar all the way to the vatican
so you made this for the pope
both john paul ii and benedict the 16th
not to mention dozens of cardinals have
worn their embroidered vestments
from papal hats called miters to the
stole worn around the collar
no matter the client holy or more down
to earth
armando and rosanna always pay obsessive
attention to detail
you have to be crazy to do this work he
says we don't do it for the money
we do it just to see if it's possible
when you see your work speeding across
race tracks
on tvs across the world that must be
really satisfying
that's true says armando i may be an old
man but i'm in love with my work as if i
were a little boy
now these artisans and many others in
the area make so many race car steering
wheels
more than anywhere else in the world
that this picturesque backdrop is known
locally
as steering wheel valley for cbs this
morning chris lives say
outside verona italy you know i don't
know a lot about automobiles or
mechanics but i think the steering wheel
is a pretty important part
yeah you need one of those yeah it's
kind of kind of what makes it all go
yeah